hallo leute herzlich willkommen zurück
weil sie german wir sind heute in der
meisterschüler in mumbai in die religion
in namibia genau wissen heute in namibia
ihr habt das wahrscheinlich schon
mitbekommen
wir machen gerade workshops zusammen mit
dem goethe-institut hier in namibia und
heute sind wir an der martin luther
schule und in der martin luther schule
lernen die schüler deutsch deswegen
werden sie euch heute mal auf deutsch
ihrer schule vorstellen
los gehts hier ist michael von
hallo die 18 schüler diamanten oder
schüler in namibia
wir stellen euch heute unserer schule
vor
aber zu ihr stellen wir uns selbst fuhr
hallo ich heiße witze hallo hallo hallo
hallo ich bin tasche
hallo ich heiße hallo hallo ich heiße
michael hallo hallo ich bin
hallo hallo ich heiße das ist unser
motto ist unser easy german team ist
heute in der martin luther high school
zu gast die martin luther high school
wurde noch zu apartheidzeiten in der
namibischen statt karibik gegründet und
befindet sich heute ungefähr 70
kilometer westlich der namibischen stadt
omaruru da die schule auch deutsch
unterrichtet hat sie uns für einen
workshop eingeladen
in diesem video stellen euch die
schülerinnen und schüler ihre schule auf
deutsch vor
das ist unsere schule bürger das sind
unsere klassenzimmer am abend vier
klassenzimmer für diejenigen schüler und
sechs für die anderen schüler
quintin was hast du interessent in
deutschland gelebt hier habe der leute
die heute war sehr freundlich und ich
habe mir immer gut und sicher gefühlt
das ist unser deutsch klassenzimmer wir
möchten heute über unser lieblingstier
sprechen
was ist dein lieblingstier mein
lieblingstier ist eine katze wie ist ihr
name und volcom ist sie mein name ist
max berchtenbreiter und ich kann mir aus
deutschland prima was machen sie
ich unterrichte hier an der mls für
sechs monate lang deutsch warum lernen
die schüler hier deutsch deutsch ist
eine verbreitete sprache in namibia
viele menschen hier sprechen deutsch und
außerdem sind um die 80 prozent der
touristen auch deutschsprachig das aber
ist es auch wichtig für die schüler sich
später mit touristen verständigen zu
können und vielleicht dann auch in
dieser branche zu arbeiten
wir spüren viele frösche den es brechen
hier das ist afrikaans ist nachhaltig
wirkung asiens kurve kommt martin
luthers cool das ist endlich das ist
tamara sie das kolleg st
wenn ihr unsere schule besuchen wollt
dann seid ihr immer willkommen
die schule hier schlafen in hostels das
ist unser schlafzimmer und hier ist das
mädchen hoster und das ist mein zimmer
was ist das besondere an der schule ja
ich war auch ein schüler hier
und dann habe ich auch mein deutsch hier
gelernt oder studiert und dann besonders
ist dass es wirklich sehr ruhig ist und
dass man viel plänen kennen wir haben
kein champions wir haben kein geschäfte
hier und so und dann ist es nur die
gebäude die horsters die gebäude von die
lehrer und so so die ruppigkeit ist für
mich wirklich besonders sogar unfair ja
unser essen
das ist unsere halle hier sind wer
unsere schule legten im team aus
getrockneten amaru fluss
das ist unserer pohl aber er ist leer
weil wir wasser handel haben
sofort begannen ende vierter
jeden sonntag gern wär ja an die kette
wir sind jetzt auf dem berg war für
moment den sonnenuntergang
da unten ist unsere schule
unsere schule liegt in der region
hallo ihr lieben das war sie also unsere
erste episode easy german aus namibia
falls ihr euch immer noch fragt warum
wir eigentlich in namibia sind das
goethe-institut namibia hat uns
eingeladen hierhin zu kommen und jetzt
sind wir für vier wochen hier um schulen
zu unterstützen die deutsch lernen denn
tatsächlich lernen in namibia sehr viele
schüler deutsch und wir machen mit ihnen
workshops das war unsere erste episode
aus der martin luther high school und
wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen auch
wenn es mal etwas ganz anderes war etwas
besonderes diese woche ihr seht zwei
episoden den wehren so viel produziert
das möchten wir euch nicht vorenthalten
also vergesst nicht die neue episode die
zweite neue episode auch zu gucken
gleich noch danke fürs zuschauen und wir
freuen uns wenn ihr unser projekt
weiterhin unterstützt das könnt ihr hier
unten machen wenn ihr uns bei petri an
unterstützt und natürlich abonniert
unseren kanal wenn mehr easy german
sehen möchtet hier unten
danke fürs zuschauen und bis zur
nächsten woche